来吧 喝在聊聊怎么拍东西听
今天这条视频是一条干活
是一条完整的框架
基本上你在短暖频里面有多少问题
我差不多通过这个框架都能给你解决了
差不多是这样的
我发现很传绝对短暖的理解都是错的
因为你对短暖频的理解是错的
所以你的行为通常就会偏离回到
就是要办就是产生不了结果
要办的话就是你华的经历太长了
想到啥说啥
我回来也比较晚 还得送回家都十点二十了
那很难说你想到啥说
你这么不责任吧 对吧
这千是一条系统
为什么我说我拍短暖频有的时候
拿着零拍
其实是因为我有一条系统
不是我想到哪说哪
谁上是因为我本身就是有结果的
就是支持的重点是一点着不少
只是我在拍的时候
因为想到点说他没有挺很准备
两个的说其实我是犀生了劉亮
对说我我不会像很多人像
我在地方设个高红字
这地方要有情绪
这地方要把那个红颗怎么样
其实我是犀生了劉亮的
另外一个就是想到点说哪
就是因为你五家都是有的
因为你平时就支持都是现场的
我都会表达出来的话
语言没有那么多准备
可能会有点弱
所以可能我们就是讲了讲的
就卡扣了
对吧 有可能
讲究你的干管不着很好
但是支持的第一岸是非常重要的
我们先说三岸
今天和大家分享三个点
其实我们下午的时候
晚上的时候
下午的时候
后边老婆姐
聊一下就老婆姐
问一些问题
包括创业的包括短视频
然后我和他快点说的
我说其实就这三个部分
第一部分就是叫骑士这次
骑士这次
很熟吧
很显然他不仅仅仅是用在
短视频里
他也适合用的创业投资
对吧
第二个就是要购点骑的系统
我不救了那个气材
我用这句话来告诉你
就是让你明白
他要打开什么意思
窮人基本上
靠得说提令
靠的是时间
但是
负人用的是骑动
你们能明白
我说他意思就好了
就不要就这个刺激行
要购点骑动
要用骑动去运转
这三个部分要形成弊话
首先我们说第一个叫骑士
说骑士这次的这个材料
我有好多人问
我说胡子哥怎么解释
一天拍一百条
我一天要拍多少条
我还是拍多的还是金的
我怎么随职
怎么定位
首先我说一下
一天拍一百条
我是绝对不同意的
严重不同意的
为什么严重不同意
因为这个邮件都是错的
其实一天拍一百条
就让你多练
我照片本意上
你多练
让你有成功的概率
就是你拍一条
戴一条
你拍五条
和拍七十五条
最后得到结果的成概率
不太一样
但是为什么不同意
大家怎么去做呢
借大家多拍
但不同意
你拍一百条
为什么
因为首先第一个
就是你
你如果拍了十条
二条
你的数据都不是很好的
通常证明
你的方向是错的
这是最重要的
另外一个的话
就算你拍成了
对吧
你拍成了
你拿我来说
我拍一条视频
我都不用准备
一拍用视频是五分钟
有些时候你可能还要钱
就算你一条是五分钟
一百条是五百分钟
五百分钟
五百分钟一天
八个万一有时
我没算错吧
你干嘛呢
你不打
不是打多次的
你跑着拍视频
那个有什么意义呢
对不对
所以你要做的是一条
点一百条
但是为什么
我说的一早期
你还是要多拍
因为你早期的目的
是为了失错
很多时候一开始
就要定位一开始就垂子
你开始定什么位
你又不了也用户
又会不了也你
平台也不了也你
你定什么位
你啥都不知道
你上来你吹一吒不了
你带去尝试
所以尝试的过程中
你就要去拍拍的时候
其实你要每拍一条的时候
你都知道你在拍什么
你在试什么
这个也很重要
如果你不让你拍什么
你试什么
你拍一百条
你拍一天
亲戚牵套有什么用呢
所以每拍一条什么的时候
知道我要拍什么
我要试什么
这条什么出去后的结果是什么
所以各位
你如果试了试条
笑我还不好
那你要看一看
就同样的主题
同样的那种
别人们是不是拍的也不好
如果别人拍得好
对不起
那啥呀
那其实就是
不是内容的问题
不是选题的问题
是什么
是你的表达的问题
这个时候你要练表
你要知道
你要在什么地方
发生改变
对吧
如果这个主题都不好
其实就不适合拍
对吧
对不起
你说为什么没有流量
整个用过人群就那么多
对不对
所以
真的在某一
在拍了很多条
之后发现没有结果
那么
这个时候你要学会
即使之分
不是不拍了
是换一个方向
换一个选题
换一个形式
不要再一条
当上走到黑
所以我还是推荐大家
早期要多拍
但是一定是
用实验数据的
所以
他个投资
和做事一样
方向有整确
刚开始就要是
但是方向有整确
如果方向错了
即使之分
你一直拿着
乱票是吧
第二个是重点
叫什么呢
叫购建系统
就是
为什么我说
我拍视频的这个
效率会很高
因为拿来又可以拍
是因为我有系统的
那系统是什么的
我简单跟大家说一下
首先输入
就是你有没有输的来源
你的输来源是怎么
你是怎么出来输入来源的
我给大家久了一早
现在我每天早上
把孩子送到学校
之后
我基本上都会散步
散步的时候
就是一个是降高学
又有高学
就是
身体很重要
身体
身体都玩了
你干嘛
那另外一块
散步的时候
回去
有灵感
就会下
所以观察
有灵感
然后有一些灵感的时候
我就会
AI很方便
有一个想法
说出来
说出来以后
这条那种过去
就到我的原谅夫妻
我的夫妻
就开始自动拆解
拆解完
回来以后
已经把我
洗好了
现场的素材
就可以拿来又过
就是
我的无论是
经年的书记
长文
房谈
我的兴趣源
都是非常好的
然后
还有一块的话
大家在做书的时候
我的建议是
我自己是怎么做的
我的灵感
苦和知识
或是分开的
就好多点在哪
就是
每天要现象灵感
然后要现做
做做的不合适
有重新走
这些灵感是需要发散
才有灵感的
然后
你创作的时候
其实是有的时候
捉人住
这是要收件的
那就相当于
一脚用门的一脚
撒成一脚用门的一脚撒成
这边灵感
要发展
这边的适合
对不对
所以我呢
其实分开的灵感的时候
就是没事
我因为照顾姑娘
有些时候
特别有灵感
或者是上面的灵感的时候
或者说地铁的时候
特别喜欢做做
工作车
我有车
但我现在就工作车
就是
五分钟是
跟中文有一些灵感
就这个时候
睡觉时间
我就会想
灵感发到的
从记得那个位置
灵感
然后呢
我处理完
知识这个知识
一个单独的哭
那每次看内容的时候
就灵感哭得一项
看爱这条内容
是不是是合的
然后我再去
往下拍
好
这个很有
很有用第二个部分
就灵感不知识
分开的
然后你来源也很重要
第二个部分
就是
还在心痛灵感的
就处理那个部分
又很重要的
前面的个位置
我是不是说你暗击吃之色
其实
又回到记得知识的
这是先拍的
那么其实是所谓的话
其实你会发现
你要去选对一个方向选对什么
就是你要知道你的用物人
你只知道
你能帮他们解决什么样的问题
当然
他们为什么喜欢
你能给的听过什么价值
哪有这个感言的
有的这个东西之后
你试出来以后
你才会有什么垂直才会有定位
否则他们让垂直定位的
回到我们刚才的那个
系统里面
输入圆眼油了
那么当处理的时候
它是怎么处理的呢
其实首先
他有点像产品
你像我以前是说产品
我以前做个产品
做产品是什么呢
我拍的
我不认为
就是显示我本彩的地方
我也不太关注
这个本彩
所以你看我伴上
我被个十个女人嫁给你
我待关注是
甚至我都很喜欢
我是工程师似的
所以我拍的我视频
我就会想
我你看我头视频的
并得来什么价值
你看我到现在拍的
我拍十分钟了
对吧
我能给你得来什么价值
你看我是平平用的什么地方
对吧
你一定是让你感觉
我听完了以后
欧洲有价值
价值很大的
对吧
所以
我的用户是谁
我能解决
他的什么样的痛点
我提供了
方法是什么
能解决的什么的问题
在什么场景下解决
能拥有多大时间
我导臂的时候
这个概念
我会把那个知识
转化成对应有用的东西
这一点
为什么
他重要
因为这样的内容
他是
好
他是资产
对我是资产
对你是资产
他会一直有用的
三年五年
他都有用
他不是留心
第二个我这种内容
他不会有特别高的流量
但他一定会有流量
对吧
就像我跟你讲的一句说
比如我调统
我调统
我就是调
当你能解决
我调统的问题的时候
他你落不落所
是不是产临
是不是很快能在地打案
是不是刻吧
都不重要了
对吧
因为我就是能帮你解决问题
这就是我说的
我在第二个部分
除了一层
我是想
我调统是派给那个用户的
能解决他什么的问题
然后接得吧
下作
当然
我不处理这个问题
我早期是怎么用的
我不用了
但你们要有
比如说一条视频
就要有流量
你是要比如符合算法的
符合用户情绪
所以前面的三秒和五秒
你就要把用户心一进来
所以你一上来就要告他
我的问题有什么样的问题
那就有什么样的问题
或者是反常实的
或者是很意外的
对吧
然后你会发现
每过几秒钟
你要想
这时候情绪要分散了
对吧
很多人就是
我们讲
它是有结果的
那我个人的话
是不用结果的
我现在用另外一个结果
什么结果
就是你会发现
又会回到前面了
就是我内容
处理的时候
我的所有内容
都会有知识卡片的方式
就是我处理内容部
它都是有一个
规定的格式的
什么格式呢
就是这个样子
我给大家
一定要包含的
四部分是拿四部分
第一
一句话要点
就一句话就说清楚
这个知识卡片法用的
第二个部分
它的基礎
就是为什么
它解决了
什么样的问题
为什么
它为什么能解决这个问题
第三
到底该怎么操作
第一部第二部
第三部的四部
第二部的四部
这四部编接条件
就是在什么情况下的
使用什么情况下
它不是用
你们注意到的吗
就是
简单来说
就是一个
有这么一个许词方法
可以用来解决
什么问题
它为什么它能解决
在什么情况下
使用
是不是就是一个问题
一个解决不安
你看这种东西
它就是
我的知识
都一定是可以运行的
让存放那种双化学约的知识
我吹满的都是可用的知识
那这种知识也就说明白了个位
你会发现我再给大家讲的时候
我会说派软的平时不先搞死的
有着派啊
你说你这么长时间都是都是
都是这个已经到底吗
是,是已经到底了
你说他旁边都听得起
不需要
体验自己影响我的发挥
影响我八到的速度
为什么
你要明白我的知识卡片
大家注意到了吗
知识卡片的格式
整好和我派短视频
我一是一样的
又派短视频是什么
又故是谁
我那个的这个什么样的问题
怎么解决
是这样的吗
那个我的知识卡片的格式是什么
是他解决什么样的问题
怎么解决的
不斗是什么
什么情况下
不是有疑惑的问题
那我说出的时候
什么就可以变成
影响形容方式
对吧
第一个,我告诉大家
今天我要讲什么东西
为什么能解决
我有证明
然后告诉你1235
是不是干货性的内容
你说我需要准备吗
那么多现场的
只是把它说出来而已
或者什么呢
就是我告诉大家
我今天要给大家讲什么
我要就有什么问题
好,为什么能解决
然后具体1235
是不是这样的
其实就是不需要准备
所以他也这一种格式
这种格式就是我驱敲了
这种驱敲就是我
我不以流量为核心
不以所谓的流量为核心
但是台阶段会有一定的流量
台阶段会有一定的流量
你以为我并不会有要
这个
然后
处理想完了
第三个部分就是
内容
就是你开始播了
那我播的过程中的话
基本上就是
不是我不准备搞死的
我推荐你们刚开始做的时候
如果你专门做这个话
我建议你们是有组思搞的
组思搞本身就是思搞的过程
所以你拍的时候
可以但不要背
我拍之前是这样的
就是我要知道我要讲什么东西
我今天要讲什么东西
但是我的内容一本人现场的
所以我只需要按我那个
个事用话把它说出来就可以了
我要跟大家讲的是
拍东西要那种第二个
要要真成
要真成
然后呢
延织有屋就可以的
然后
很多人说
还要渐渐
还要配司末
能像我就是
已经到底外
要配的字幕
然后前面一卡头
后面一曲
就玩事了
当然现在的话
我会把视频的那个内容
变成文字
然后认给AI
让AI帮我
帮我输出图来
然后贴图
让你看到这个重点是什么
然后让AI
输了一些变成文本
我的评论区就是我的内容
就是我的文本的内容
这就是我拍的说要系统
我跟大家讲
这些系统
我都是有现场的AI提示策的
就是
如果我想做这个事情
从有想法到最后
口波文案出来
其实就是一个
你有的是
现在我反而不做了
这是我们讲的
因为他熟了
而且就已经真的是
形容他已经运作了
所有反而不做了
第三个问题
叫什么呢
叫一定要形成弊患
什么叫形成弊患
就是你拍完了以后
我刚才说了
你拍的时候
你之前是无标的
你做了什么做短视频
你可能是不在正前
你可能是被的流量
你可能会被扩大影响力
对吧
你可能会
人事
IP
对不对
那
你最后拍完了以后
你又没有打到呢
你要看这个数据的
对不对
你特别再会流量
那就要看点赞
看评论啊
还不会换了呀
对不对
但有的时候你是为了
为了市场严重
那你就要看评论了
你要说自己是不是干活
你要看关注
关注的人数
或者是搜场了
对吧
那有可能
比如说我就是为了
赚钱
对吧
但早期的时候
你没有那么多份
是有标记
比如说我独立本书
自己不喜欢的东西给别人啊
真正的好东西
OK
这边说真的好
那我就给大家分享
我看那边说觉得很好
我也不夸大
就是真的觉得我这边说
放在这儿看看
那么他买着去
那卖着去好
你现在也不夸
对吧
这个说为什么你看
我不是特别关注的人
因为我有一套系统
所以我知道
我想要流量的时候
我就可以有流量
不是说我拍一下
什么就肯定会暴不是这样的
它是有一套系统
是
我不保证我拍一下
我视频一定会暴
但是我拍两三条中间
一定会有条什么是暴的
因为它掌握了一套系统
对吧
这个就好像什么呢
这个差别的人
就好像很女人是买菜票的人
就是
指望这个
拍一套什么
没头什么都暴
我们是干嘛
我们那边是个概率
就是你可以把我们的理解
就是我是那个装剑
就是独场里面
不知我那个装剑
我不能保证我每一场都赢
但是我保证我最后一定是装的
这就是系统的多期
好 各位
我今天讲的稍微点长
因为回来以后就要挂
我每个孩子们没想到的大叔
他就有点长
但是那种手可以的
然后我建议就是可以把他搜尝一下来
以后你遗亂那个卡应的时候
你一对应我简单给你做个
总结啊
首先第一个部分
就是你要即使是是是
早期的时候
有些早期的时候
没有什么定位
没有什么催尺
你就是要不用的长事
尝试的公共发现不合适究几十之岁
不合适可能是这个塞造不合适
可能是后来的情况不合适
但一定不是因为难不合适
至于这个方向不行
或者他不符合我
什么叫不符合我
他确实有了
但是我很累
我不想做人生苦断我
来干嘛的
对吧
最我有喜欢
最后做的一个是我有喜欢
我很轻松就把这个人做成了
但是这个方向有很好了
不行就其实认识
不要是磁掉了
拍着十条二条条
最后效果还不行
不是因为我我方法的问题
那就肯定重新再选一个塞造
第二个不一定要购劲性
购劲一种有输入的部分
你我建议你要有灵难苦要有内容苦
然后你要有处理知识的
就是来源一定要好
第二个部分的话
就是在处理的这个过程中的话
你最好要有一些模板
对吧
一些模板就是一些有产品
所以就没有用花下
你的内容给内容给他
大概什么样价值
他为什么会喜欢看
同时可能会有一个结果
你像我就是干货的行的就是
我今天搞的还有什么东西
为什么他会是这样的
结果是什么
步骤是什么
对吧
你看我的结果就这样的
然后第三个部分就快就拍了
你慢慢想着习惯的灯光
你的什么
你想我就不太在乎
但是我虽然不太在乎
但我已经重新了
就这么效果也是OK的
对吧
然后我的去拍摄
然后像我就已经到底完了以后
省事儿已经到底是最省事儿的
然后家头去给八文资一配
很省事儿五分钟十分钟的出来的
然后呢
出来以后你要看出去
要不要先弄笔坏
我如果是为了播放量
我叫一定要看播放量和点赞
为什么播放量
笔笔点赞
第一 我要去想办法
播放量的原因什么
是我的三秒半
某个某个某个某个
你的点赞是没有共情吗
对吧
那我要关注的是
我的内容是不是符合什么的需求
对吧
我就要测试我的话题
OK
我要看凭论的
是不是干活要看收藏和关注的
对吧
我是为了证险
那我就要看我到底有没有卖手东西
大旁边出一单面出两单
我只要做那么出一单的两单
它这个笔缓是OK的
那么有了这个笔缓之后
你才会有底气吗
对吧
所以一个三部啊
第一 第一 第一十分
第二个 高级行动
比香港部分
形成笔缓